the right rises the hard revolting right
rises it feeds off immigration but it
rises when those DC politicians on the
right give it room to rise and doesn't
fight it i watch marine lepen rise and
it was when the conventional parties in
France bent towards her and the advent
of you Kip and its rise is because the
Conservative Party did the same thing
and mod an angular Merkel is an example
of what you can do to lead a nation to
another destination Churchill called us
the mongrel nation and so we are we are
the product of succeeding waves of
immigration into this country that makes
us what we are and this is the mongrel
city and it is the most successful
global city in the world because of that
place a barrier up to it as the
gentleman over here once and you remove
that I disagree with the idea but it's
only Muslims who are responsible for
overturning our values you've always
been able to find gentleman over there
was right young men who will see who
will think it is part of a noble calls
to kill innocent people that was the
amicus of the turn of the 19th century
it was the baader-meinhof gang it was
the road army faction I don't have to go
to Baghdad to hear a preacher preaching
death from pooted I can go to Belfast
these have always been there and it is
wrong with Malcolm Rifkind to ascribe
this simply to Muslims these are people
who wish to overturn the values who
happen to be Muslims but we've had
plenty of Christians seeking to do it
look we haven't got all the answers this
is one of the really great conundrums
challenges moral and practical to
confront us I know some of the things we
ought to be doing and are not doing but
I haven't got a solution to all of these
we're going to have to think but I tell
you one thing if you do not do this on
the basis of your humanity then you will
be left with only one way to do it moats
and walls and barbed wire and then you
lose your humanity and you create
another reason for even more walls
you